the most important thing is realizing
that fundamentally you're a slave to an
egotistical construction with either one
and the goal is to transcend that even
though your egotistical construction
that you're feeding is societally
rewarded right so that's a trap that you
could really really fall into so the key
is you need to go a little lower than
that
we are both funds of Charlie who put and
he says that when somebody asks you what
do you do you have the opportunity to
hook lots of different things in so if
someone was to ask you why do you do
what you do what's the single thread
that ties together all of the things
that you do
what would you say though
that's interesting I feel like there's
been like an evolution like throughout
that because
just what I do I guess
it's like change like over time
because like now like broadly speaking
like on the surface like I make like
YouTube like Fitness oriented videos but
I think that started when
I was like 13 or 14 years old like I got
into like weightlifting and then I took
a lot of pictures of my progress made a
transformation video then ended up going
viral
and then I just like started making a
YouTube channel just with like my
friends in the gym just making random
videos of working out and then I guess I
started being more interested in making
cinematic ish like content and just
making it more like I don't know
sophisticated like higher quality like
Etc like more autistic
and
yeah I guess
I just enjoy making videos that I just
enjoy making
do you wish sometimes that you're
entrance into the world of virality
social media YouTube hadn't been
so tightly defined based on the way that
you look the gym or do you like
integrate that as part of your history
perfectly fine
I'd say so I mean I'd say at an earlier
point maybe like years and years and
years ago it was to the point where
there was like a like I guess a slight
like toxicity component to it
because the whole reason that I got into
working out was because of like very
like generic stereotypical insecurities
as being like extremely skinny feeling
all that
and then as I started getting more and
more progress in the gym and then that
obviously gave me like a self-esteem
boost I thought a lot better about
myself and then I would like take
pictures and then obviously when people
take pictures oftentimes they just want
to like maximize it to get you know the
best lighting angles Etc and then I got
to a point where maybe like a few years
into
working out where I had just a decent
bit enough of muscle to get pictures
that look like semi-decent right but not
in those pictures like in real life like
without like a pump or whatever I
remember just like feeling like still
like very like just like skinny and
insecure
and then it was like a problem because
even say like my senior year in high
school I remember I would just wear
hoodies just all the time because if
you're wearing like a big baggy hoodie
you can't exactly tell like like the
size of an individual even though at
this stage you're probably one of the
biggest guys in yeah I mean I wasn't
like gargantious or anything the sort
but I definitely I I look like a normal
reasonable human being with like an
acceptable amount of like muscle tone
right but still in my head there was
like this crazy just Distortion body
dysmorphia and then eventually the way
that transferred over to social media is
it was like that thing just Amplified
even more in terms of just needing to
look as good as I possibly could like
pictures recognizing you for it yeah so
if like I take a picture with someone
and then my physique didn't look like as
good as like I thought it would like in
my own pictures that I would take or
just buy myself in like particular
curated environments that would
definitely wreak havoc on my well-being
and that was definitely sub-optimal but
as more and more time went by I feel
like that General complex just naturally
like dissolved there's been a bit more
peace where were you at now with you
know because you're still what you're 24
uh I just turned 25 right okay so you've
been on the internet for longer than I
have despite being 10 years younger than
me right
given the fact that you have had this
long career from basically when was when
did that first video go viral 17 18.
what the age that I was I was about 17.
yeah so you know a good chunk of time
that you'd spent with an awful lot of
eyes on you on the internet all of this
has been based around the way that you
look you know this is coming out the
back end of the like aesthetic bro like
Jim's era type thing
how have you managed to dispense with or
how much have you managed to get rid of
that body dysmorphia that sense of your
sense of self-worth being attached to
the way that you look you're leanness
your size
I think the way that that dissolution
happened to whatever degree it has
happened was
through just so many years on end or
such a prolonged period of time of just
feeling such internal like discomfort
and dissonance and just oh yeah just an
overall sense of like discomfort in my
actual day-to-day life having to just
like micromanage just my own like
self-image
of how I think I look yada yada this is
that and then it just got to the point
where that was just so unsatisfying to
operate in that way that
the more and more I would distance
myself from that like organically as a
byproduct of like achieving a certain
like understanding of how that makes me
feel
then I would just notice it would just
not feel that way anymore but even like
throughout the years like at times I
would have
situations where I could just see my
brain re-entering previous thought
patterns that I did when I was like
fully ensconced in that mindset but back
when I was fully ensconced in that
mindset that was literally my like
reality as I was like having those
thoughts and feelings but now
that previous thought pattern still
exists but it it exists within a broader
understanding so that when it arises I
could just recognize this arizal and
then it'll just go away and then um
just like I don't know at peace or I
feel fine like there's like no like
issues really so I don't know I didn't
like necessarily Implement like just
like a strategic like plan or like take
any steps or like create I don't know
like a mental hygienic discipline to do
that it just it just sort of just
organically just happened after just
like contemplation and stuff
talk to me about the introspection and
the self work that you've done over the
last few years
because just to interject them I'm like
you're you're a young guy right you're
25. I was like an adult infant at 25.
and the way that you're talking about
letting go releasing difficult
challenges that come up is very mature
especially for somebody that's had
broadly the internet world at their feet
for quite a long time and I'm fascinated
to work out how you go from that a
static bro thing to now
a still a relatively young age taking
value in different stuff what have been
the practices the thought patterns the
influences that have got you
I'd say one of the main reasons that
happened is just my natural disposition
of being extremely introverted so for me
I
spent a lot of time by myself that's my
recharge period yada yada like we all
know like how like introversion works
like basically so for me
just
just long periods of time just by myself
just thinking about [__] are you an only
child
no I have three brothers okay yeah just
thinking just obviously listening to
just lots of podcasts like lots of great
thinkers just borrowing like thought
patterns from other people and just
building this larger like conception
like in my head and then contrasting
that with my own insights and things
that
I've just experience and
yeah just just lots of just just lots of
like thinking because I feel like that's
how most things are like typically like
resolved like there's an idea that
I forget like there's lots of people
that talk about some sure you've heard
people talk about this too but if you
if you wanna
like for example like you're familiar
with like Naval ravacon like him talking
about like prescriptions or like if he's
spoken to an individual like like
Capital group
oh yes
no way correct has he actually yeah the
no prescriptions prescriptions guy was
it an audio only podcast correct yeah so
I mean you get that whole idea like it
basically
I feel like so if an individual is like
struggling with like any source of like
body dysmorphia image issues like Etc
one line of thought is like okay you're
like I have an issue like I have a
problem I have like anxiety I have the
stress I have all these like things
going on so one school thought I was
like okay let me okay I have issues
right I need to fix issues so let me
like Implement like certain like things
and regimes to like combat these
problems which is like useful in
moderation to a degree but I feel like
for just a really really deep
internal authentic transformation you
can't do that by following just certain
like oh let me just write down like in
my like gratitude Journal like 15
minutes a day like every single day like
let me just like have this like Mantra
like meditation kind of pattern maybe
that works in some people to some degree
but in a certain kind of way there's a
type of like insincerity that goes with
that because you become obsessed with
doing the
doing the the surface level generic
action to get out of your state of
distress as opposed to just
sitting and being in the distress
without any agenda and just just being
there and in that state
just naturally you somehow
just wiggle out of or dissolve or just
TR transcend like the issue per se or
you don't even transcend it you could
just understand it on a deeper level and
this is that deeper understanding that
gives like health I suppose if that
makes any sense it does well I think
that an interesting question might be
how many of the strategies that you use
to deal with the things that you don't
like about yourself or about your life
are not helping you to deal with them
but are helping you to escape from them
so yeah so I just remember so I remember
so when I was like young when I was like
13 14-ish like 12 or whatever I was like
very insecure I was like skinny whatever
right so like I saw like you know
muscular people that I look up seems
like oh look I want that right so then I
followed a bunch of people I gained like
a lot of inspiration and I did like what
I needed to do to like build my physique
and then I think I was around the age of
like 18 19 20 like sometime around that
time and then I think that's when Jordan
Peterson like first started popping off
and um I was like listening to a lot of
his content and I was like whoa there's
something about this like resonates so
much I remember like feeling
just that I
we just like have like certain just
interesting ideas or like things going
on in my brain but they couldn't like
come out just right then when I would
listen to Someone Like Jordan Peterson
speak I had a very specific admiration
for the his ability to so precisely with
perfect congruence of what's Happening
internally what he's saying externally
to be at a one-to-one ratio with Just
Like Music orchestral grade Precision
with like his like delivery just almost
like you regardless of what he was like
saying it's like destruction not the
concept of a speech that I just had like
an admiration for in addition to the
things that are obviously said as well
so then that I feel like
launched my brain into wanting to just
like develop in those like General
regions like categories and stuff so I
would just listen to like so many other
people the Sam Harris's um Alan Watts
Etc like all these like different people
so then I remember like reaching a point
of like I was like 20 21-ish and then I
had a general feeling of just like the
whole body dysmorphic yada all this like
stuff was just like catching up to me
all these like generic whatever like all
these problems that me and like so many
people deal with
and then I went down to the prescription
path right and the prescription path
would have been like I started going
into yoga all the time and then I had
this like huge ego complex like showing
up on time like doing all like my poses
like extreme extremely well because I'm
like if I'm like doing this right and
then I also like I'll like sit down like
I'll meditate in the morning for 30
minutes whatever I was like so obsessed
and excited to do that because obviously
you know the thought pattern is doing
these things will like alleviate me and
like get me out of like my problems or
whatever
so then I feel like it's a very common
thing for like so many people to do and
then they become obsessed with doing
that I became obsessed with doing that
and then I felt like huge bursts of
dopamine throughout that right because
I'm like oh checkbox like yo the session
finish like this thing finished like
this like food like eating right and I
would just feel like so excited but it
was almost like a short-term just
pleasure seeking fixation on like doing
that and that it actually didn't like
really like solve anything underneath
you've still got the the existing
problem okay so you've got in the first
instance an issue with body dysmorphia
or dissatisfaction with the way that you
look you fix that by finding people that
you like the way that they look and
modeling what they do
then you find people that you admire the
way that they think and you compare the
way that you think to the way that they
think you then start to model off of the
way that they think what are the
similarities between or what is it that
you were looking for do you think in
both camps of people like what is it
that ziz and Jordan Peterson have got in
common that seduced you
it's a great line what are the things
that ziz and Jordan Peterson Ivan Carmen
I say that it's to you to you
entertainment of something that I for
whatever reason deemed to me deemed to
be
admirable and non-negotiably necessary
for me to have
and in this is obvious case it's you
know muscles uh Jordan Peterson brain
Etc but so it's just their
accomplishment of something
yeah and I feel like you could almost
tie that into I don't know if you could
tie that into the general concept of
like masculinity but
yeah I'd say to me it's just something
that they like achieved that I for
whatever reason just wanted
to have what sounds to me like if you
want to roll masculinity into this
you're trying from first principles to
come up with like what is a modern
renaissance man you know how do we have
the body the brains the humility the
benevolence the altruism the Insight the
self-awareness you know the the power
but not the Tyranny the money but not
the greed you know how do we hold all of
these things together
one of the challenges that I've been
talking about a lot on the show at the
moment is finding a firm place for men
to stand in the modern world and this
isn't just good for men right because if
you have good benevolent strong men they
make pretty good partners usually on
average like they're good for the women
as well and they're good for the
community and they're good for the
society and they're good for the
civilization and the GDP and the
economics and all the rest of the stuff
given the fact that you have spent a lot
of time chronically online for the last
10 years
what's your
conception of
male role models at the moment the
challenge of masculinity why do you
think it is that a lot of young men are
feeling lost uh and requiring more and
more of these role models
I think there's many different like
interpretations like one school of
thought or Camp is like oh there's
there's been a disruption of the nuclear
family unit and there's like some
conspiratorial reasons for that some
non-conspiratorial reasons because you
can go under the hypothesis that to you
know have a more or less successful
upbringing you want the standard nuclear
family unit mom and dad and then with
that being like fragmented fractured
then that creates all sorts of problems
so if that is the case then the the
quote unquote child boy like in this
instance isn't getting a certain type of
isn't getting like a healthy proper dose
of masculine energy like within like the
household under the assumption that the
household is fragmented for whatever
reasons then that need still needs to be
satiated and because it's not being
satiated at home
due to the easy access of the internet
then that role models will be found like
online so like in built in like
intrinsic like in like The Human
Condition is like that like need for
that like kind of energy and if it's not
being like given at home it's going to
be needs to be supplemented elsewhere in
all this case online and depending on
the maybe maturity level of the
individual
or just how the individual is wired that
like certain people gravitate towards
these types of online figures other
rules like rotate in this I mean not
rotate resonate or connect with other
people that they find on the internet
and I think that the reason that
people like Z's like Jordan Peterson and
all like that are um
influential and have like resonance is
because they're arguably supplementing
that need that a lot of people aren't
getting in the stereotypically standard
Classic Home nuclear family-esque kind
of way
yes
I think yes I also think that even if
you do have a nuclear family the rules
and procedures that the generation
before ours had you know
if your dad grew up and never had the
internet until you were born
how is he going to be able to fold in
understanding the way that social media
Works understanding the way that online
dating works the crazy crazy changes
that we've seen with regards to men's
roles the metoo movement all of this
stuff
I think that even the best meaning
father in the world from the previous
generation
might struggle to have the language to
be able to communicate with a kid that
is growing up yeah no for sure times are
changing so fast things are changing so
quickly that you know the previous like
rule set or whatever
although it may have like certain
fundamental pillars or parameters that
will be universally applicable for any
timeline whatsoever
when things change as they inevitably do
like things approaches need to be just
like micromanaged and nuancedly like
tweaked and then no one knows exactly to
what degree that needs to be done like
it's so easy to overshoot or undershoot
and because the rules like haven't been
made yet we're essentially figuring out
like on the fly like what's like
happening correct I also think that it's
more than uh perhaps just a micro tweak
I think that the last 30 to 40 years has
been a bit of a left turn as soon as you
introduce the internet one interesting
thing that I was considering on the
plane ride over here
for the guys that didn't come up uh
living on ziz and that Aesthetics bro
era a lot of that was about pulling
girls at festivals it was sort of quite
chauvinistic it was uh harmless and
funny and self-deprecating but there was
still a lot of that like sort of gym
flirtation energy in that how do you
think in 2023 given the
politics that we have at the moment
given the hypersensitivity around
approaching girls in the gym given the
Advent of me too how do you think if you
deposited ziz in 2023
that kind of content would be received
now do you think that he would survive
without cancellation
someone like ziz
I think that he would survive without
cancellation probably because
I think like extremist people like that
that I mean they Garner like a certain
like audience like the more Niche or
extreme you could be like you'll
cultivate an audience and obviously like
a lot of people also dislike you as well
and that'll like add to your benefit in
terms of like social media like
expansion so I mean there's like plenty
of people that many people deem to be
detestable but they're still extremely
prevalent on the internet so
no I mean I think all things considered
I don't think this would be like
canceled per se today because I mean
there's so many other people that are
like taking on like the ziz-esque manly
energy and just like passing you know
taking the torch that he you know passed
on that are still living in those
General like kinds of ways so I think
that I think he would probably flourish
just fine objectively speaking
talking about this I'm fascinated about
this trajectory right that that you've
gone on specifically
um what changes if you were able to
create what you think the world of men
that are around about your age need
right now in terms of influences and
influences
what do you wish that you could see more
of in terms of the sort of content
that's out there in terms of the kind of
messaging the kind of values the sort of
things that men should be aspiring
toward and the things that they should
stop aspiring toward as well what would
you try and prescribe
I think generally speaking like a
reduction in materialism would probably
be a good thing and I think the
additional emphasis on
just developing like a confidence like
any domain whatsoever whether it's like
Pottery you know exercising working out
like whatever it is so it would be I
think it'd be better
to
shine more of a light on
people's genuine like ability and
attainments and skill level in whatever
their idiosyncratic or generic just
Pursuit and Endeavor is and just have
uh appreciation for that in and of
itself without any with a significantly
less emphasis on the periphery of the
tangible material assets of that that
type of success could like yield
so homozy on an episode that I did with
him a couple of weeks ago said far more
people are kept poor and stupid by their
ego than get rich off it yeah and you
know he made this great point that if
you are somebody that considers yourself
to be a high performer uh that is
pushing and always trying to grow and
you're able to retain your ego it's
because you're in the wrong room and his
point was even though he's now worth 100
Mil he's got this acquisition.com he's
doing these massive deals
he is permanently in rooms where he is
both the stupidest and poorest person in
the room
how can you allow an ego to proliferate
and grow when you're permanently the
lowest wrong of the ladder and his
argument was basically that ego comes
from people
artificially Walling off the size of the
pond that they get into to allow
themselves to always be the biggest fish
but also I feel like it comes down to
their deepest most fundamental
motivation because for example you could
take someone like Alex he desperately is
a wired to do something and wants to do
something just like work build his
Empire business whatever that's like his
sort of thing so he just he simply needs
to do that to be satiated happy and like
satisfied right so that's just what he's
on and in order to be able to do that as
effectively as he possibly can manage
that would
necessitate and require a very high
level of like self-awareness and
obviously self-awareness is the
antithesis the ego so that's just simply
what he what he wants to do and then you
could take someone else that is like the
small Pawn like ego situation their
primary most fundamental desire isn't
doing something for its own sake or any
you know deeper reason like that it's
simply towards the the growth and
maintenance of the ego right and that's
just simple that's just what their
motivation is like they're simply
they're more interested in like having a
certain self-image of themselves and
doing everything to convince other
people of that image and commit some
cells of that image because to them
that's more important than other things
so it's just a
a a different hierarchy of like
priorities right so like yeah the lower
level development psyche is going to
want to favor just egotistical-ish types
of things
how do you square this circle with the
person that's listening to this and
going hang on you're David [__] laid
like you're Mr Instagram ziz era like
how have you made that change how have
you made that transition from being
somebody who outwardly it seemed like it
was and you mentioned yourself it was to
satiate your feelings of insufficiency
to now get to a place where I mean how
many videos have you posted on YouTube
in the last year probably less than 12
how many Instagram posts have you done
in the last year less than 20. it's been
out of decline
but my point being that
from where I can see and I didn't get to
hear you on podcasts before I think that
your trajectory in terms of how you're
sounding to me in terms of the things
that you're thinking about is [__]
phenomenal I would have happily taken
the sabbatical from social media if what
it's resulted in is you being like this
but
how do you get to that point there are
guys on the internet that are watching
the ego lifter the materialist
Ferrari driver the Richard Mill red
louboutin's bottom table at Club live in
Miami
what is it that can drag those people
out of that or what would you say to
those like young guys if you could why
should they be bothered about this thing
which seems hard and difficult and
nuanced and no one gives a [__] about
except for their own sense of
existential self-worth
I think I think a lot of those people
that like operate like that like they
have like a vague understanding that
like maybe the way in which they're
operating from a lot of other people's
points of view is like seen as like
negative egotistical immature like Etc
so they have like that like General like
awareness and they're maybe aware that
they just to satisfy you know
Society at a whole you know expectations
of them they would maybe like cease or
halt or like slow down on some of that
behavior or like you know Elk Road or
Etc but they're like aware of that but
they just they just they just don't want
to do it because going back to what I
was saying before that's just simply
like they're just more interested in
doing that that's that's like where the
current level of like their development
is so
in the same way like to me the own the
way that I outgrew whatever like I grew
like whatever time like it came from
just like just organic like
introspection so going back to kind of
what I was like saying in the beginning
like you just simply you need to just
examine you need you just need to just
like like look at what you're doing and
just like look at how you're living and
look at how you're operating and just
like like dissect it as much as you can
and be as on like be honest with
yourself obviously and like look at it
and I feel like if you're genuinely
sincerely doing that right you're more
than likely to realize how that pattern
that style of like living is just
disadvantageous for your absolute best
interest and through coming to that
realization you just organically stop
doing that you don't have to see the
difference yeah you don't have to
discipline yourself to stop doing like
oh I really want to do it but I want to
go to this but I can't like no you just
won't have that desire and that's the
best place to be at because why do you
want to like it's just where you got to
arrive you know so there's my favorite
ever blog post of all time is by a guy
called kailash and Rhoda and it's called
what do you want to want and he talks
about the difference between once and
what we want to want so once our
societal programming their paths at
least resistance that the way that
you've dealt with past trauma they are
all of those things
what you want to want involves you going
in and reprogramming your desires you
want to end up at a place where what you
want
is what you want to want and he uses
this example of the fact that if you
don't go in and program your desires the
best thing that you can hope for is to
be a rich successful or famous slave a
slave to the impulses of your body the
confused biochemical signals that you
get the desires of the people around you
and when I read that and this is you
know five years ago now I thought
what do I want to want in life
genuinely what do I want to want like I
have the opportunity
laws of thermodynamics and like a little
bit of Economics restricting I can want
anything
this is what we're talking about here
we're talking about
digging away at all of the layers of ego
and predisposition and expectation that
you've built up and getting yourself to
something that's firmer getting yourself
to something which is what you
want to want
foreign yeah I mean I I think there's a
lot of validity in that because
basically like what you're saying is
like you a person wants certain things
and then maybe he realizes some degree
like these just kind of this maybe maybe
isn't my best interest like silly like
little hypothesis lurking in the back of
the mind okay so if I'm an autonomous
being I could I could more or less
curate or decide what I want to want so
if that's a possibility let's just look
broadly speaking what are some of the
things that would maybe be in more of a
best interest for me to one and then you
decide those things and you fixate in
that pattern I mean fixate in that
direction and even if you you could
argue that that's still
prescription-esque to some degree but
then you could also say that doing that
is better than just continuing wanting
those like sub-optimal things so if that
if that's what gets you moving in that
direction then it's absolutely yeah and
direction is more important than speed
right like you can be going as fast as
possible in the wrong direction and it
actually takes you further away from the
destination this is something that a lot
of people I call it the uh monopods
which is mid-20s toward late 20s these a
lot of guys it seems like you had yours
earlier realized that a lot of the
values that they hold a lot of the
things that previously they took a sense
of self-worth from that the world told
them that they should value
they don't make them feel fulfilled
anymore and they go oh [__] like I I got
toward the top of this mountain and I
realized that it was the wrong Mountain
that I climbed and actually I was
supposed to be on that one over there
and it's difficult because in order to
get to that one you need to go back down
this one that you've already climbed you
need to dispense with the stuff that
you've that you've got rid of this is
what I think introversion is such a
cheat code because like I feel like
you're less at the mercy of other
people's designs because even like for
me I noticed that if I'm
the more frequently and the more for a
sustained period of time I'm involved in
certain just patterns of behavior
oftentimes socially or just just what I
do in general you just become locked in
those patterns and it becomes more
difficult you have more of like a narrow
perspective so you know the brain's
Malibu it just gets programmed in that
way and you're just kind of operating
that way so for me a lot of like the
best insights that I've gotten are like
times when I like completely just like
fully detached and just enter this weird
like meditative just like Flow State of
just being just so just alone
yeah so it's just
I feel like yeah I mean almost a
prescriptive thing that you could say is
to just stop I mean that's what they say
like psychedelics do I think I heard
someone on Joe Rogan talk about he had
like a nice analogy it's like the brain
is like
like a hill covered in snow and then
when skis go down the snow that's a
thought Behavior pattern Etc and the
more you have it the more deeper that
Groove gets and then the psychedelics
they just like wipe the snow correct so
detaching from society detaching and you
know reclusing yourself for a period of
time it's like a micro form of like a
psychedelic snow flattening kind of
thing because you're removing the
external inputs as best you can removing
the inputs stopping the behavior
patterns just allowing yourself to see
things differently and have different
patterns for the people who are thinking
about monk mode
um there's a really great blog post by
illimitable man if you just search
illimitable man monk mode
13 years old now I think but it's really
really great there's the three eyes
isolation introspection
some of the [__] there's a third one
anyway that I really really enjoyed that
blog post and that was good to me one
thing that I do find and this is me
almost directly like telling it to Hamza
my friend
monk monk can be taken to an extreme and
you can do
you can obsess over isolated
self-development too much yeah the way
that I the way that I would look at that
is like monk mode could become a
detrimental extreme when monk mode
becomes hyper prescriptionized because I
feel like the way it becomes an extreme
is like you're like okay I want to
self-improve myself just monk mode right
so they need to become obsessed with rpe
10 just maxing out like monk mode so
there the true fundamental motivation
isn't understanding things the true
fundamental motivation is to feel good
about yourself from maxing out monk mode
for the egotistical grad because yeah I
mean like just how we talked about how
you say young individuals like
materialistic programmed by Society like
wrong values and stuff the reason that
they're doing that is because that
satisfies their ego that's been
programmed and programmed into them
right someone going all out monk mode
right
upsellably abstaining from all of that
right there there
they have the exact same ego but the
subtle difference is that they could
feel a sense of just like moral
superiority right because like I'm
better than you because of all of that
but in reality they have the same ego
it's just transmuted into something else
this is a very important point that I
want everybody to take home which is
you can justify any kind of activity as
being the thing that is going to give
you a sense of dopaminergic I achieved
the next thing just because you have
switched one type of obsession for
another type of obsession does not
necessarily mean that that obsession is
more holistic You could argue given the
choice between being obsessed with the
gym and being obsessed with taking
heroin that the gym is objectively a
better Obsession to have but if you're
going to get really down to zero
what we're talking about is how can we
sit with the discomfort of not being
enough how can we sit with the
discomfort of not having an obsession at
all what does that feel like and this is
like almost a psychedelic point right to
get rid of to get rid of the desire to
need those things overall
um
you know I feel like that
that's a very good point the idea that
like yeah like doing heroin or whatever
or like versus like working out in the
gym like it's a similar kind of
egotistical Pursuit but due to like
I mean obviously the working out it's
like the healthier thing and the
externality of one is very different
exactly so that's what I'm getting at is
the the externality could be like
drastically different for example like
you could be addicted to heroin or you
could be addicted to just like rampant
entrepreneurial just Financial just
right Hedonism and that and then again
due to how Society is it's celebrated
but like you said it is the most
important thing is realizing that
fundamentally
you're a Slave to an egotistical
construction with either one and the
goal is to transcend that even though
your egotistical construction that
you're feeding is societally rewarded
right so that's a trap that you could
really really fall into so the key is
you need to go a little lower than that
yep I agree it's a very difficult thing
to do
to let go of something which is not
destructive
reinforced praised gives you accolades
and really importantly like you said
gives you the moral High ground it's
like look at me look at how awakened I
am this is a term that you might I might
not be familiar with called spiritual
bypass so have you heard of this before
yeah so um people that go to
being South America take a ton of
Ayahuasca come back and proselytize
extol the virtues of this amazing Peak
experience that they've had don't do any
of the integration don't do any of the
self work go back to being the same
maybe not even a piece of [__] but just
go back to being the same person that
they were before and then go and do it
again right that's spiritual Bypass or a
better I prefer spiritual tourism that
you can go and like visit it like a
holiday home and come back and forget
about all of the things that you learned
the goal is to integrate each of these
different points here so one thing that
was very formative for me and I'm
interested to find out about your
experience as well I had a pretty
serious back injury about four years ago
got into CrossFit uh was way stronger
than my body could deal with
and managed to slip two discs I found
Stu McGill number one back pain
specialist on the planet
I know that you have worked with him too
how difficult was it for you as somebody
who had a lot of his self-worth wrapped
up in the way that he looked
to have that taken away from you by
first off a back injury
and secondly by what I'm guessing if
you've followed what Stu told you to do
was an unbelievably slow painful very
humbling process of slow Rehabilitation
so just get tied real nicely so
so with me due to having all the body
dysmorphia insecurity just like needing
to work out to feel like the validation
self-love self-worth Etc right that
other extremes that that pushed me into
is just like how like intense like I
would exercise right I would just you
know horrible form lift as much as I
could just pain tolerance like push
through all of that right and deadlift
Sumo as well so here's the thing so from
one point of view it's like wow that's
so admirable like you just work so hard
you're so disciplined You're So
Dedicated that's just so amazing good
for you but if you you know look behind
the curtain a little bit that's not this
that's not that altruistic and pure of
like an energy source right it's a toxic
energy source and that toxic energy
sources and the insecurity and then
basically
that led me to just severe injuries of
my spine because horrible form lifting
heavy weight blah blah so
with that right
it's almost like my back injury is
a personification of
being fueled by
a toxic fuel source right and then
the thing is like someone could have
told me back in the days oh like you
know you shouldn't be like lifting this
heavy you shouldn't be doing this you
should have been more careful right and
that's me being like aware that maybe I
shouldn't be doing that in the same way
as someone that's like living a very
hedonistic young immature egotistic
lifestyle is also vaguely aware that
maybe shouldn't be doing that I had that
same awareness too but even though I
knew that it just didn't matter because
my my goal was like so egotistical at
the end of the day which is why the back
situation like needed to happen to me
like it
well yes in a certain kind of way but I
feel like it was inevitable to happen
because I mean one school of thought is
like for people to make like a proper
Jurassic change like they need to hit
like a form of like rock bottom right
I was having this thought the other day
maybe it's like hurted someone I don't
remember but it's like
swimming along the lines of like wisdom
is often if not exclusively attained
after like like a rock bottom-ish type
of situation but then
ideally you'd want that wisdom like
beforehand but paradoxy can only be
gained after like a rock bottom like
kind of thing so it's like this weird
Tango inverted Loop thing
but yes I mean like for me that kind of
definitely aided in a lot of the um
just introspection or like growth or
whatever just like having like that back
situation happen because it forced me to
just like slow down like like I was in
such debilitating pain that like not
only could I not deadlift or squat like
the weight that I wanted to I couldn't
deadlift squatter all I couldn't work
out sometimes how I wanted to I'd just
be laying in bed with just chronic
debilitating pain
and
to get out of that really wasn't that
difficult at all I mean it was but when
I say not that difficult Alma and it's
just like stop doing stupid things that
hurt you and like rest but how my brain
was wired at the time that's not an
option like I just need to go go go go
go go go go go go go go go so it hit a
point where
so you can almost argue that it wasn't
this just altruistic transformation it
literally hit a point where the back
pain was so debilitating that I would
rather kill my previous ego
and start from scratch then I would
maintain that ego and tolerate the back
pain because before it wasn't back pain
was here ego was here still more worth
it but when when those scales like tip
just the right amount it was an organic
shift because I literally just had no
other choice so I literally constrained
by your body yeah so like I had to start
from Ground Zero
and I mean yeah that's changed like
not being so extremist all out in the
gym like being very like patient
disciplined careful with like how to go
about something as simple as like
training where in the past like oh I
feel good tonight Max just all the time
and
so I feel like that new mindset now that
I got from dealing with my back injuries
has definitely permeated out like into
other areas but I think it arguably
needed to happen to Checkmate me into a
form of like introspection so me too me
too man uh it came at the right time I
had spent all of my 20s being a
commercial Man model uh walking around
with my knight with my top off and
nightclubs uh getting photographed by
Dean and um
or a lot of my self-worth was wrapped up
in that you know even though I wasn't
doing the online thing to the degree
that you were
I still was like the guy that was in
shape I was always the like one of the
biggest one of the leanest amongst my
friends and that gets taken away from
you and you think
oh [__] who am I now okay who am I now
when all of the things all of the places
that I took my self-worth from
are gone
well [__] like what what's left because
this isn't going to be here forever I
had uh thought of a quote the other day
which was
um
your looks are a depreciating asset your
mind is an appreciating asset invest
yourself worth appropriately
like everybody no matter whether you
think that your sexual market value as a
guy is going to Peak at 45 like there is
going to come a time where you get over
the top of that hill and it's going to
start descending like even [__] David
Gandhi right is gonna start descending
at some point you have the opportunity
to invest in something which is
Evergreen which is going to compound
which is going to benefit the rest of
the world and that's not to say the
people that are in shape can't benefit
the rest of the world it's good to be
motivational so on and so forth
but especially for women I think there
was this story about Paulina parikova
who is a supermodel
in the 90s 80s and 90s and she's now 56
and her husband had died and there was a
famous story that came out about her
about a year and a half ago and she was
lamenting the fact that as a 56 year old
she walks into parties and none of the
guys look at her anymore because they're
all distracted by the 23 year olds that
are in the room and she was saying you
know a lot of my self-worth I feel
really terrible and so on and so forth
and
it made me sad it made me sad because I
was looking at somebody who was still
taking their fundamental sense of
self-worth from the way that they looked
with I think two or three kids
um and it just it doesn't feel graceful
do you know what I mean like it doesn't
feel like somebody has has allowed
themselves to to get Harmony and Grace
and transcend and include the things
that they had before and also there's
obviously a massive amount of like
hubris and hypocrisy here because when
you were 22 you didn't care about the 56
year old that was in the room that all
of the guys looking at you were ignoring
to look at it's like look this is
the Ark of life
everybody knows that it's coming
everybody knows that your looks are
going to fade that you're going to
become sick or ill or destitute that
you're going to run out of money that
the people around you are going to die
and all that you're going to be left
with
is the power of your thoughts right how
much resilience do you have that you can
rely on
so that when the hard thing happens you
have somewhere for him to stand
and if the firmest place that you have
to stand is I am single digit body fat
you were in for a hard [__] time
yeah
um
any you know external metric or just
anything that you like latch onto you
know whether it be your body fat
percentage or your
youthful looks that diminish with age
that you just get outside your bank
account like forms a status like Etc
just yeah if you become I mean it's like
a Buddha saying like you just become
like attached to stuff it's just a
problem it's just not good but
there is an enjoyment in you know having
like like a huge bank account or
enjoying your looks to a very very high
degree don't don't get me wrong like you
need external accolades right like I'm
not saying that we can like dispense
with say it's a primal hair hierarchy or
whatever yeah
yeah but it just
I guess I guess it will put it like yeah
like that stuff is necessarily useful to
like certain like healthy degrees but
obviously not sufficient necessary but
not sufficient
necessary but not sufficient and
it's just yeah I mean it's like a
spectrum of like the more you like rely
on those kind of things for like the
like well-being and like happiness it's
just you just you just run into problems
and it just and like like you were
saying like you want to be in a state
where
when all is like said and done and it's
just you that you have like something
like firmer to stand on so
yeah what
are your thoughts about the modern world
of dating especially for young guys do
you think about this much there's a lot
of advice out there for young dudes with
regards to dating especially to do with
gym videos approaching girls in the gym
and the lack thereof and the challenges
of guys approaching and so on and so
forth what's your conception on this
I mean
I guess modern dating like the internet
is obviously played like a massive role
like the whole
dating apps
that being a situation
um
I mean I think obviously speaking things
like the internet have like
drastically reduced like genuine like
human-like discourse where like in the
past
a lot more conversations where like in
person that were like real because like
when like two people are saying
communicating over text it's such a
narrow dialogue when you're like with
someone in person there's like all these
just energetic components intangible
micro facial expressions like all of
that and that's preferable slash
arguably needed to have like a maximally
rich and satisfying insatiating like
Human Experience overall with people
like in any relationship friendship s
kind of context so I think just like the
simple idea of that that being reduced
due to the introduction of the internet
although the internet obviously has a
lot of benefits you can meet people
around the world different areas Etc
there is like that like obvious downside
and
with that being said
there would be like an isolation
component as well to you know
socializing with real people less and
then living in your own head and then
communicating and just meeting and
talking to people on like dating apps
and stuff it and then you could just
start downloading and integrating
certain just like toxic ideologies on
male female intersexual dynamics that
could have some tidbits of truth but
without contrasting it and integrating
it with your own like real experience
because you have none because you're
just isolated and extracting ideologies
online that that could be just a massive
detriment to your dating life
dude I've been harping on about this for
so long I did an interview
for uh a new the redone sub stack of
what used to be ideas sleep furiously
and they've changed the name and I can't
remember what it is and they did it we
did a little interview and they talked
about um why is it that men seem to be
struggling with the advice that they get
online and remember for the girls that
are listening you need the advice that
men get online to be good because you
are the one that's going to have to put
up with these [__] men right so my
point was
if you're chronically online and most of
your experiences around male to female
interactions have been mediated through
the internet
what are the kinds of stories that are
the ones that go the most viral online
they're the most egregious they're the
one where some terrible catastrophe
happens and the guy comes home and loses
his house and his left foot and she she
takes his like all of his hairline in
the divorce and that's the story that's
going to go viral yeah and you can
almost parallel this with prescriptions
because if you
don't have
real you know sufficient amount whatever
that means of a real experience with
real people and you're just you know
getting ideologies online or just
hearing worst case catastrophic
scenarios Etc a lot of like um
theoretical Frameworks that could be
laid forward kid in isolation in the
abstract makes so much sense and the
math could like run out and like it
works out especially when
extreme scenarios like added upon that
and then
when it comes to dating advice just like
like what you should say to approach and
this is that like the more prescriptions
like you add on it just becomes just
like such a disaster and but then people
can think oh but how do I do this whole
thing if I don't have any like
prescriptions or like know what to say
or how to go about it right
but the thing is paradoxically so if you
like lay that like to the waist side
right and then you're like around like
people like speaking to people girls Etc
whatever it may be
a certain organic chemistry arises if
you would like Let It arise but the more
weird prescriptions and layers like you
add on top of that you're just like
[__] the whole thing up and it just
becomes off so paradoxically leaving
that to the waistline your body and your
instincts will take over and they'll
just like know what to do right but so
that's almost another way putting it the
Advent and introduction of the internet
dating apps Etc has suppressed the
natural organic Instinct in favor of
just
weird
toxic arguably toxic like programming
with you know how to go about things and
that just crates just in a GMO inorganic
disaster yeah so this prescriptions
thing I think we just need to drill this
home for the people that maybe aren't
familiar with kapil's work the point is
if you don't have any real world
experience the only place that you're
going to get any tactics from are things
that have been told to you that you've
never actually come up with in the real
world but if you were to spend let's say
that you could live for eternity and
have an unlimited number of interactions
if what the prescriptions are are
accurate you would inevitably arrive at
them in any case if I gave you a million
years to work out and you didn't know it
the the most effective way to get a bar
from the floor overhead in one single
movement you would eventually Arise at
something close to a snatch because it
is simply reality and Theory coming up
together Constantine kissing the guy
that does trigonometry quoted this
unbelievable line the other day that
said in theory theory and practice are
the same in practice they're different
just a thought that I was having as you
were saying that is so you could like
pair this whole prescription idea like
from the dating back to like like
working out for instance like you have
someone that's never worked out before
right but they'll sit and they'll learn
like all like the theory and the this
and that Etc and like what their
personal ideal regimen would be and then
come up with that and then if they try
to execute it if they even bother to do
so like sometimes it will like fall
through because just
their bodies are different like how
their lifestyles are set up so
yeah even prescriptions could be like
detrimental in something even a simple
in the realm of Fitness because if you
just like start like doing it right
if you want to go all out and be like
the best of all time then obviously
you're gonna need to follow like certain
things but
the problem I have with the problem I
have generally with kapils and I I had
this problem when I spoke to Kapil on
the show the issue I have with Kapil is
no prescriptions point is that unlimited
degrees of freedom allow people to find
things through experience however
you need guidelines and guardrails why
are we talking about this crisis of
masculinity where guys are lost and
alone it's because everything has been
been blown open if everything is
masculinity then nothing is masculinity
right and you go okay from first
principles please work out how you are
supposed to show up in the world and you
go dude that's really really hard and
you what you want me to do that for diet
and my role in society and the way that
I should make money and the way I should
interact with my friends and the way
that I should get a girlfriend and the
way that I should become a father like
it's [__] exhausting
the best way that I found for this and
this is where I diverge from kapil's
work the best way that I've found from
this is that in the beginning of
anything you need instruction because
you have no experience to rely on you
don't want to become dogmatic about the
instruction but you do need to take it
so you explore at the start and then you
exploit over time do lots of different
things find out what works for you and
then over time once you have learned the
rules you can break the rules but
breaking the rules before you learn the
rules is just not playing the game
yeah no I agree with that I did such a
poor job of expressing what I wanted to
with that um
parallel with prescriptions with working
out but yeah I mean obviously if you're
getting like into fitness like you
you're gonna follow like something like
vague program in general I think the
idea that I was like trying to get at is
you're better off like
taking a random workout program whatever
it may be just going out doing it seeing
how you respond to it just seeing how
much you like working out in general
maybe you don't want to be a heavyweight
bodybuilder maybe you just want to work
out a few times we can get in shape and
that'll like satisfy you but you won't
know that unless you actually try so
that's all fine what I was getting at is
not doing anything just having like all
like the theory like what works out and
then it's just not being like a
practical like execution in your actual
life it was more something like that but
I agree with the Nuance like obviously
like you can't derive absolutely
everything and just know how to just be
like work out from first principles
obviously like when you're a kid like
you need to be taught language you need
to be able to talk your shoes those are
prescriptions from a certain point of
view yeah so yeah that was where I got
caught that was where I got caught with
Kapil stuff so I did a newsletter that I
wanted to read to you uh from the other
week and I think that this is this is
very very interesting it's something
I've been thinking about a lot
this is from David Goggins it's so easy
to be great because most of the world is
weak if you are even remotely a Savage
you will run these people over it's all
out there for the taking right now
that's Dana White
everyone rails against the victim
mentality that seems to be sweeping
certain areas of the world I get it you
don't want your town or country or
species to go to hell because everyone
has forgotten how to take some
discomfort or deal with challenges in
life but on another hand this rampant
fragility is your competitive Advantage
the bar has never been set lower
a bit of consistency a bit of
intentionality a bit of resilience and a
gram of talent will make you into an
absolute killer I also understand that
you probably want to raise other people
up along with you having a greatness
stand on the shoulders of the world's
fragility may seem exploitative and I
love the idea of not just improving
yourself but changing those around you
for the better
but there's a limit your efforts are
multiplied by 10 times when building
with the right people and by 0.01 times
when building with the wrong people if
someone refuses to alter their habits or
update their worldview or improve their
life despite being given all of the
tools and encouragement they need by you
then they can stay where they are it is
not your job to drown Yourself by trying
to keep others afloat who don't want to
change
humans don't mind hardship in fact they
thrive on it what they mind is not
feeling necessary modern society has
perfected the art of making people not
feel necessary that's Sebastian younger
it's easy to be a Savage when everyone
else is a [__] but sometimes it's hard
to find a sidekick what do you think
about that
what does that mean that last word
sometimes with the sidekick that if
you're with the right people your
efforts are multiplied by 10 times and
if they're with the wrong people then
they're restricted basically
yeah I mean I can go back to like the
simple saying like you're like the
average of like the five people that you
surround yourself with and you gain
exponential momentum in the direction
that you're going with so if you're with
a sub-optimal set of people with values
that aren't in your best interest you're
going to be
accelerated in an accelerated fashion
going in the wrong direction what about
this balance between fragility of the
modern world being a competitive
advantage
well I think with a lot of those people
like the gogs and the few that you said
like that it's a very like
stereotypically Uber masculine kind of
like mindset which is like fine right
but I feel like
sometimes that can be taken to an
absolute like ridiculous like extreme
but the right amount of that is like
like a good thing like what are you
aiming for what's an integrated version
of that to you
I like the idea of
having an indestructible mindset being
able to overcome
like obstacles and adversities and
having that like
just like that just focus intensity
but I think that
sometimes you can get
just exclusively like fixated on that
like for example
with David Goggins
he went through just like extremely like
traumatic stuff like I've like heard him
on so many podcasts and like I've like
like audiobook like a good amount of
like his book so I know like the
backstory the dad Etc is really just
like horrible stuff
and for him
I just all the experience and everything
that he's gone through just in order for
him to be able to like Thrive and come
out of that he needed to adopt a certain
kind of just like just indestructible
god-like mindset which he did achieve
the coping mechanism yeah exactly that's
exactly it it's a coping mechanism in
the same way that you could look at um
me working hard on the gym when I was
younger oh that's like so admirable but
reality that the fuel wasn't like the
most like positive thing so this you
could make a semi-ish kind of like
parallel to the David goggin situation
because of what he went through he
simply he needed to adapt that way it
was a necessary coping mechanism and
his situation was so extreme and he
talked about it just so well like
poetically which is so much like passion
and intensity that a lot of people when
they read that they resonate with it
like tremendously especially if they're
like lacking that if they're lacking
just like the discipline and that kind
of stuff hearing someone like David
Goggins give you the theoretical
framework of
being able to overcome stuff combined
with his own
painfully visceral experience of it
it'll just give you Goosebumps hearing
and if you have a depletion or lack of
that in like your own character you're
going to naturally gravitate to like
someone like him and he'll kill you yeah
exactly you're going to get the benefit
in the same way that
people would be inspired by me working
out when I was younger and that would
benefit them even though the fuel source
pushing me wasn't like the most cleanest
form of gasoline
so although mindsets like that are
extremely extremely useful and Powerful
in like certain circumstances but I feel
like
because I mean I feel like for like a
David goggin situation like
like at a certain point like
he might even go like deeper when it
comes to just his just like character
Arc just like his like development is
like a human being
I just had the parallel for example is
like someone like Mike Tyson like when
he was like super young just like
indestructive like super villain like
and as he's like gotten older like a lot
of his like temperament has just like
simply transformed like he was so
aggressive and just intense like when he
was like younger because I don't know
his full situation but maybe it's a form
of coping mechanism maybe it was just in
his DNA to be like that but he would
just like that then over time
he just mellowed out in a certain kind
of way and that's not better or worse of
mailing out that's just like the arc
that he's going through but then you
could say like if David Goggins I'm not
David if uh Mike Tyson was that exact
same way that he was when he was younger
into his old age where he is right now
you'd almost look at that and be like
there's like
like there's still like fixation in a
previous behavioral pattern that's no
longer included well I think the point
here is
that kind of
almost like a resentment that very
visceral powerful
um
scarcity mindset
is an unbelievably potent fuel but it's
really [__] toxic yeah I mean I
wouldn't it can be toxic in certain
instances I don't say I don't think it's
like purely like toxic like in I say
toxic to you it's toxic to the inside
like yes it's very very good like being
driven by a sense of insufficiency can
cause people to do unbelievable things
right it almost all of the high
performers that I know are not driven by
what it looks like from the outside and
what it should be proselytized it's this
beautiful balance of you know fulfilling
the the logo speaking forward and
manifesting your essence it's not that
running away from something which makes
them feel insufficient there is a voice
inside the head that is a disparaging
parent it's a bullet school it's a
teacher that didn't believe in them it's
an abandoned sibling
something inside of them is saying you
are not enough
the only way that you can make yourself
enough is to perform out there in the
world and if you perform well enough
maybe finally the world will accept you
and you will be worthy of love that is
an energy that [__] every single high
performer on the planet except for like
three people can resonate with because
running away from something that you
fear is an unbelievably potent Fuel and
running towards something that you want
comparatively is less so
but if you use the fuel that pushes you
away from something that you fear for
too long you will end up having
malignant coping strategies
and it will burn everything that's
inside of you as well [__] powerful
but it's going to make that engine run
at a very high rate it's powerful and
you'll need to use that fuel for a
certain period of time when it's needed
but then it's important or ideal for
your best interest to want to just like
transcend and like go forward correct
another quote so this will be everyone
will have seen this by now because the
whole Mosley episode will be out but it
wasn't out before this and what he was
talking about as you said was um some of
the challenges and the setbacks that
people have and how that could
give them the justification for maybe
not being where they could be and he
said this really great quote which was
if you have suffered from sexism your
entire life if you have suffered from
racism your entire life you would be
absolutely justified in not being at the
place where somebody who didn't have
those disadvantages is
however the advantage that you do have
is that unlike me or you or homozy you
can be a role model to those people who
did have those problems because I can
guarantee you that there is someone who
had it worse
and did it better
and he said that and I was like holy
[__] that is so good because for me
somebody that went through challenges as
a kid uh who had a bit of a chip on his
shoulder about not being in
uh not feeling like I was supported and
having to do a lot of this work myself
like I had to [__] pick myself up by
my bootstraps first principles okay what
do I want to Value how do I want to do
this let's build a thing on my own twice
and
getting rid of that like getting rid of
that chip that was on my shoulder
without using it as the bitter like I'm
doing this to prove the [__] bullies
wrong I'm doing this to prove the people
that didn't believe me wrong I'm doing
this to prove the place that I came from
that didn't have the big enough Vision
to help me wrong
the way
that
that became was made alchemized to feel
more holistic
was that I thought okay well there's
other people that are going to be
feeling this too
those are the people that are going to
go through these challenges
not only can I beat the setbacks that I
feel like I had
but I can also help other people from
get past to get past them too and I can
be like look here's the pitfalls here's
how you expedite success not only did
this thing not get me but it's not going
to get you either and that's the best
way I think to transcend challenges and
traumas that you've had in your past not
only do you beat it
but you help everybody else to beat it
as well you know I completely agree it's
like the tipping scale up you could
either have it lean in the in the toxic
resentful like direction or you could
optimize and leverage it in like a
greater scale benevolent positive like
way that's definitely the way to go
what
do you want to how do you want to serve
the world
no
like you've got creative director at
gymshark whatever you are your new job
role you have a massive amount of reach
you have as far as I can tell the raw
materials to be able to go and do pretty
much anything you want along with a [__]
ton of time
how do you want to serve the world now
I'm not entirely and enticely I'm not
entirely precisely sure
I'm still working on that exact agenda
and like figuring out like the most
optimal way to do that but
like the ideas came on my head is like
for example when they talk about with
like when you're like raising like
children like when you're like
apparently like the kids like hear
nothing that you say and like see
everything that you do it's almost like
the person like that you are
he's like what
sub communicates at the highest level
like
to people
basically if if you're if you're a
certain kind of if you live or exists in
the right kind of way like whatever that
means like as a parent to your kid then
the kid gets like it has like a healthy
development as opposed to doing
everything incorrectly but saying like
all the right things so for me even
though I don't know like precisely what
I'm gonna do like in a tangible fashion
to just like help
Society of the world at scale
as I'm figuring that out like the thing
that I'm putting emphasis and priority
on is just like
like living in congruence or just
feeling just like
optimize and just like aligned with like
with just how I am as a person like how
do I operate on just like a daily basis
even like with the most like subtlest
little things what's that highest sense
of self what what are the things that
you value the most when you're operating
at your highest level
what do you genuinely take pride in
um well like lately for a good amount of
time now it's just been
I guess forms of like like artistic
expression like in a sense whether it be
like something as like simple as like
making like a YouTube video that's like
like cinematic or well-made like in a
certain area or just
coloring and like editing just like
videos I don't know just like just like
simple things like that I don't know
like lately I'm finding
a very high degree of just like
intrinsic my bad intrinsic satiation
with
doing
I guess just artistic things in a way
and like and what about personally
like what is it that you when you show
up for yourself
like what are you most proud of so I'll
give you some of mine so it's when I
tell the truth
like when I tell the truth is the most
important thing yeah and I mean for me
like when you initially said that that
was like one of the first things that
came to mind but
but yeah no I mean that's like like
that's like a huge one too and like all
like micro like little situation because
it's so easy to just like like kind of
like like
exactly and you could like feel and like
sense all of those so yeah what else
you need to tell the truth what else do
you need to do come on to be the person
that you want to be what else do you
need to do
I don't have a precise answer at the
moment but I feel like with the Baseline
of just like honesty and all like the
micro and macro situations like that
like covers like a good amount of it and
like spawns out into
other things but
I feel like it's pretty all-encompassing
one I think that's the foundation yeah I
think you're right but you know for me
for instance like vulnerability learning
to be increasingly vulnerable which
again everything is a form of truth
right me saying that I show up and be
um like compassionate to my friends
that's a form of truthfulness right it's
like trying to be your best self going
forward being vulnerable
um for me leaning into difficult things
for instance like
one of the problems of
having
uh increasing
increasing number of resources and like
material success or whatever
is that success can make you soft and it
can make you lazy and it can make you
rely on other people uh which is
something that I've managed to avoid but
I've managed to avoid it mostly through
a combination of neuroticism and like
Obsession not through the you know
transcended no prescription I do not
just I simply don't want it it's like
being fixed by something which is also
still a relatively toxic fuel
um
I'm impressed by you man I think that
you're a very impressive individual I
think that the trajectory that you've
been on from where you were to where you
are is fantastic I'm really really glad
that
you've got the background that you have
and the reason that I've like tried to
drill so much into the psychological
side of what we've spoken about today is
that from the outside the
many million followers on Instagram the
you know 50 60 million
play video of the body transformation
it gives people not only a preconception
about the person that you are
but
it makes them presume that you would be
locked into a particular type of uh life
path the same way as I know like YouTube
releases a new album and all of their
old fans hate it they go well look guess
what we like it this is the direction
that we're going in now right and this
is the getting to the top of the
mountain and looking across and going
I think I'm on the wrong [__]
Mountain [__] I have to go down I need
to transcend and include uh I'm really
really glad that you're doing what
you're doing I'm really glad that you're
on the trajectory that you're on yeah
I'm excited to see where it goes it's an
adventure where should people go if they
want to keep up to date with the stuff
that you do
um just um my YouTube channel mainly
just search David laid and
yeah
that's basically it like my Instagram
same thing David laid and uh if you guys
want to have like a very natural and
healthy and optimized pre-workout you
could also buy my pre-workout at
euphoriafree.com
and yeah that's where you can find me
David I appreciate you thank you for
today my pleasure what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
thank you